what is the optimal amount of good
lookingness that a girl should have
because if you are better looking than
99 out of 100 other women all of them
are going to have a reason to have a
problem with you they tend to be women
who are attractive but particularly
sexually provocative those women get
targeted the most other women who are
competitive or really status driving and
agentic they also get targeted by other
women's aggression it suggests that
women are kind of taking out anyone who
could be a threat in The Mating domain
or anyone who's not a very useful
Cooperative partner that's very
interesting attractiveness thing is such
a double-edged sword right because we
hear about the halo effect or pretty
privileged I could imagine a world in
which it would be better to be 90th
percentile good looking because at least
there would be a small number of women
above and below you whereas if you're 99
out of 100 who are you going to be
friends with